a man pleads guilty to killing his child
and will soon now learn his fate it's a
story the 8 news now investigators have
been following since 2017. Vanessa
Murphy previously exposed how the child
welfare system may have failed to
protect this boy she's here now with
more on the case
Paul Jones lied to us he lied to police
and court records show he's still been
trying to change his story he brutalized
his own son before he eventually
murdered him in about two weeks a judge
will have to decide how long Jones
should go to prison for
Montana
this is Paul Jones lying during an
interview with 8 news now in jail after
his arrest in 2017. but nearly five
years later Jones admitted to murdering
his son and abusing him in this guilty
plea agreement obtained by the eight
news now investigators here's his
signature this is a sentencing
memorandum from the defense describing
the last moments of 13 year old Aaron
Jones life Paul Jones hit him Aaron
dropped to the floor and hit his head
and when Aaron still wasn't breathing
after he put him in the shower Jones
buried the child's body in this desert
area he's been out here for more than a
few months Jones claims he killed Aaron
in February of 2017. no one reported him
missing until April of that year family
members eventually revealed Jones
severely abused Aaron making him stand
against a wall with his arms over his
head beating him forcing him to remain
in soiled clothes encouraging other
children to taunt him and not allowing
him to eat or to sleep for days this was
in a one-bedroom apartment with 11 other
children according to records it's hard
to believe my son is dead dejanae Thomas
is the child's mother she filed a
lawsuit against the child welfare system
Jones was removed from his mother's care
and placed with his father who was on
probation for child abuse that lawsuit
is ongoing it's not something that
I would ever understand in the criminal
case Jones is asking for a 12 to 48 year
sentence
specify several possibilities including
life with the possibility of parole
after 20 years a judge denied a request
from Jones to withdraw his plea as he
may have tried to change his story again
there are still many unanswered
questions about this case why wasn't
Aaron reported missing sooner why was
Aaron placed with his dad who was on
probation for beating a child child
protective services always cites privacy
laws when we try to get these answers
back to you Vanessa thanks for your work
on this and